every day now the police are coming to
the camps and moving or detaining the
migrants but many are packed and away
before they are caught the people here
say it is this crackdown which is making
them take increasingly dangerous
journeys to get to the UK no prisons and
the pull of Britain is as great as ever
Ramy an Iraqi Kurd tells me he'll cross
soon you want to go to London yes why
what is it about the UK yeah perfect for
me for my leg the journey though is
perilous even in a seaworthy vessel but
with the cliffs of Dover visible in the
right conditions the siren call of
Britain is seductive the migrants start
their journey at first light but the
French police say it's impossible to
stop them all because there's simply too
much coastline that they have to patrol
but the expectation is in the next few
weeks there will be more people making
the dangerous crossing to Britain before
the weather gets really bad and the
winter draws in the migrant problem is a
persistent issue in Calais and brexit is
a complicating factor it's to go to
England politicians here say however
messy the divorce Britain must do more
we need to think about where the border
should be set up - should the British
border be set up in France or no more
that's clearly some points we need to
take we cannot have a channel becoming
the new Mediterranean Sea with dead
bodies lying on beach and [ __ ] both
side of the channel in the windswept
camps though they don't care about the
politics or the risks lorry or boat
they'll still take their chances with
what the smugglers are promising a lot
of training name
our friends like I know him you know so
you'll have a better life for new yeah
there's like a hundred percent and how
how will you get to the UK from here
well I have to fire bagel with your two
children and your white boys in a
freezer I still do like 1315 hours the
dream of a better life will continue to
tug people along the migrant trail to
Calais in the hope they'll reach the UK
and as old roots close new methods will
be tried here desperation is a powerful
force
Alex Rossi Sky News Calais